[Müzik]
Selamlar. Hoş geldiniz. 9. sınıflar için
üslü sayılarla ilgili bir konu anlatım
videosu hazırlamıştım. O videoda
birazcık daha temel şeylerden
bahsetmiştik. Çünkü sizlerin düzeyini
bilmiyorum. Ben de ilk kez aslında ara
sınıflar için kayıt yapıyorum. O yüzden
çok heyecanlıydım. Yorumlarınız için ve
destekleriniz için çok teşekkür ederim.
Tüm yorumlarınızı okuyorum. Yani kalp
bırakamasam da hepsine merak etmeyin.
Hepsini okuyorum. O yüzden yazdığınız
her yorum benim için çok kıymetli. Bunu
niye söyledim? İlk videoda biraz daha
soru ağırlıklı gidelim. Konu
anlatımlarını zaten elde ediyoruz. Çok
soru çözün demiştiniz. Ondalıklı
gösterimlerde problem yaşadığınızı
yazmışsınız. Ben ikinci bir video
yapmadım. Araya biraz boşluk girdi ya.
Dedim ki ikinci videoyu yapıp uzun uzun
konu anlatacağıma tüm üslü sayılarla
ilgili soru çözümü yapayım. Ardından
köklü sayılara başlayayım ve sınavınıza
yakın zamanda da üslü sayılarla ilgili
gerekirse tekrardan bir soru çözümü
yaparız. O yüzden bugün üslü sayı
konusunu 9. sınıf için tekrar ettirecek
bir doküman hazırladım. 13 soru var.
Eskiden kitaplarımda kullandığım sorular
var. Eee, şu anda eklediğim sorular var.
Eski notlarım var. Hani bir sürü karışık
sorudan sizlere hazırladım. Yorumlarınız
çok kıymetli. Lütfen yorumlarda dosyaya
eee müdahalede bulunun. Yani güzel
olmuş, şurası eksik olmuş. Bu konuyla
ilgili daha çok soru gelsin. Biz köklü
sayılarda şuraya geldik. Orayı
anlamadım. Bunların hepsi bazen kendim
yetişemezsem yapay zekaya
yorumlatıyorum. Yani öğrenciler en çok
şurada takılıyormuş diye cevap
çıkartıyor. O yüzden konu başlıklarını
belirtmeniz de çok kıymetli. Bilginiz
olsun. Şimdi biz üst sayıları tekrar
edecek şu keyifli sorularımızı gelin
çözelim. Ara ara ben yine konu anlatımı
noktasında hatırlatmalarda da
bulunacağım. Merak etmeyin. Evet. 1inci
soru. Bir organizma. Bu arada bu
PDF'leri de katıl kısmındaki öğrencilere
koyuyorum. Herhangi bir katıl seviyesine
katılıp destek olmanız yeterli
arkadaşlar. Tamamen sembolik yani
desteğinizi belli etmek açısından.
Katılın. Kendi gönderiler sekmesi var.
Orada kanalımızdaki tüm dosyalara
ulaşabiliyor olacaksınız. Bir
mikroorganizma her saat sonunda
bölünerek üç yeni mikroorganizma
oluşturmaktadır.
Birinci mikroorganizmamız verilmiş. Bir
saat sonunda işte şurası 1 saat. 1 saat
sonra ne olmuş? Bunlar 3 tane olmuşlar.
Bu şekilde bölünen bir mikroorganizma 4
saatin sonunda toplam kaç tane
mikroorganizma oluşturur? Şimdi soruda
bakın birazcık daha böyle farklı
yazılabilirdi. Önce çözelim sonra nasıl
olabilirdi onu da söyleyeyim. İlk
başladığımızda biz bir taneyle
başlıyorsak 1 saat sonra ilk başta bir
tane ile başlanmış 0 saat gibi düşünün
ya da başlangıç diyelim. Başlangıçta
tabii 1 bir tane 1 saat sonunda kaç tane
olmuş? 3'e bölüneceği için 3 tane.
Aslında bu 3 tane yerine de 1 + 1 + 1
yazabilirsiniz. Burası 2ci saatin
sonunda nasıl bir vaziyete bürünüyor? E
bir tane daha, bir tane daha, bir tane
daha her birisi bölünürse bakın buradan
da 3 tane gelecek. Peki buradan da 3
tane gelecek. Peki buradan da 3 tane
gelecek. Peki o zaman bu 3 3'ün
toplamından şurada da gördüğünüz gibi
toplam 9 tane mikroorganizma olacaktı. 3
saatte peki durum ne olacaktır? Buradan
bir 3 daha gelse, buradan bir 3 daha
gelse, buradan bir 3 daha gelse. Ama bu
3 dikkat edin aslında bu 3 dediğimiz
şeyde 3 tane mikroorganizma var. 3 tane
boncuk var. Öyle düşünün. Bu üç boncuk
da ayrılacağı için her bir boncuktan 3
gelirse buradaki üç boncuktan toplam 9
gelir. E bu sadece bir kısımdan 9 tane
geliyorsa buradan da 9 buradan da 9 yani
3 kere 9'dan artık 27 mikroorganizma ve
4 saatin sonunda da her bir tanesi 3'e
bölünecekse yine bunun 3 katı olan 81
tane bu 4 saatin sonunda şuralarda 81
tane mikroorganizma görecektik.
Cevabımız 81 olacaktı. Ama şunu
diyebilirsiniz. Şimdi ben bunu eee
aldığım aslında hazırladığım zamanda da
hani soru köküne hep takılmıştım. Yine
takılıyorum. Çözerken de takılıyorum.
Şöyle olabilirdi arkadaşlar. Bu
mikroorganizma her saat başı 3'e
bölünmüyor mu? O zaman şunu demekle çok
haklısınız. Siz başlangıçta bunun bir
tane böldünüz ama ikinci saatte bunun
tekrar üçe bölünmesi gerekmez miydi?
Bence çok haklısınız. Yani şöyle
düşünelim. Sadece bu mikroorganizma için
isterseniz buna ne diyelim? Hani birinci
birinci demeyelim ama karışacak. Hani A
diyelim. A mikroorganizması için A
mikroorganizması 1inci saatin sonunda
kaça ayrıldı? 3'e. 2inci saatin sonunda
bu bir daha üçe ayrılacaktı değil mi?
Yani şu 3'ten aslında eee Evet
diyebilirsiniz burası tekrar üçe ayrıldı
diye. Ama şuna dikkat edin. Burada bir
saat geçti. Daha sonrası burada bir saat
daha geçti. İşte burada oluşan 2inci
saatin sonunda oluşan. Ama biz şunu da
söyleyebilirdik. Bu her bir saat 3'e
bölünüyorsa evet bu şekil oluşurdu
arkadaşlar. Fakat bu şekile ek olarak
bir de ne olurdu biliyor musunuz? Şöyle
yazalım. Bu direkt 4 saati
tamamladığımızda
2inci saatte ne olurdu? Bu bu
mikroorganizma tekrar 3'e bölünmez
miydi? Elbette bölünürdü arkadaşlar
değil mi? Çünkü her saat başı bölünmüyor
mu? Evet. Bu her saat başı bölündüğü
için aslında 2inci saatte tekrar 3'e
bölünürdü.
3üncü saatte ne olurdu? Bunlar tekrar
3'e bölünürlerdi.
4 saatte ne olurdu bu çıkanlar? Yani kaç
tane çıktı? Bakın 9 tane. Bunlar bir
daha bölünürdü. 27 tane diyebilirdik.
Yakaladınız değil mi ne demek
istediğimi? Buna ek olarak şunu da
sorabilirsiniz. Hocam 2ci saatte tekrar
27 tane bu oluşturdu. Evet. 3 saatte ne
olur? E bu adam tekrar 3'e bölünmeyecek
mi? Tekrar 3'e bölünecektir. Bir daha 3
tane 4 saatte bir de buradan ne
gelecekti bu sefer? 9 tane gelecekti. 4.
saatte tek başına inceliyor olsaydık
yani 3'ten 4'e geçerkenki saatte de bu
bir daha 3'e bölüneceği için aslında
şöyle bir şey oluşabilirdi. İlk etapta
başlayan 81'li, 2ci saatte bir daha 3'e
bölünüp şuradan start veren 27'li, 3.
saatte başlayan 9'lu, son saatte tekrar
başlayan üçlü verirdi. Bu şekilde de
sorulabilirdi. Şimdi burada böyle
sorulmamış ama lütfen unutmayın burada
şekil verildiği için bunu incelemedik.
Fakat şekil verilmeseydi her organizma
bölünüyor diyorsa bunu göz ardı
etmemeliydiniz. Hatta bak yani
detaylandırmaya çalışırsam daha da
detaylanabilir şunun gibi biz sadece
buradan gidiyoruz ama e tekrar oluşan bu
ikinci saatte oluşan bir de bunlar var.
Hani bunların bir daha 3ünc saatteki üçe
bölünmeleri üç kez daha türemeleri de
hesaba katılabilir. Neyse ben belki çok
kompleks hale getirmişimdir. Siz bana
takılmayın. Böyle bir şey gelirse
şekilli verildiği için açıklamaya tekrar
ihtiyaç duyulmaz. Ama burada yanıtımız
81 olacaktı. Evet, 2inci soruya gelelim.
Bu soru tiplerine takıldığınızı
yazmışsınız. O yüzden koydum. Aşağılarda
da var. 16 üzeri 16. 16 üzeri 16 ile
toplayıp şu sayıya bölüyoruz. Ne
yapalım? Benim size buradaki tavsiyem bu
sayıları olabildiğince küçük yapın
arkadaşlar. Ne demek o olabildiğince
küçük? 16 sayısı aslında hangi asal ile
inşa edilir? 2 ile yani 16 dediğiniz şey
2'nin 4. kuvvetidir. O halde biz burada
16 yerine 2'nin 4. kuvveti yazarsak
burası 16 üzeri 16 ne demektir? 2'nin 4.
kuvvetinin 16 üssü. Ne demiştik? İlk
videomuzu izleyen öğrenciler elbette
biliyor ama üssün üssü çarpılır. İşte bu
ifade 2 üzeri 64 olarak yazılacaktır.
Yani burada kaç tane 2 üzeri 64
olacaktır?
Şöyle azıcık sizi yukarıya alayım.
Bakın 1 2 üzeri 64 buradan gelirdi.
1 2 üzeri 64 yine yanındakinden gelirdi.
Yani 2 tane varmış. Devam ediyorum. 8'in
20 kuvveti diyor. 8 ne demekti? 2 üzeri
3. 8'in 20 kuvveti ne demektir? 2 üzeri
3 üzeri 20. Bu da 2 üzeri 60 demektir.
Üssün üssü çarpılır. O zaman 2 üzeri 60
+ 2 üzeri 60 + 2 üzeri 60 + 2 üzeri 60.
Şimdi acele etmeyin. Yukarıdan
başlayalım. Kaç tane 2 üzeri 64 var? 2
tane. Peki ben size deseydim ki x + x
bunu nasıl yazıyorsunuz? X'ten 2 tane
varsa 2x'tir. Ya da x'ten 3 tane varsa
3x'tir. Dolayısıyla burada 2 üzeri
64'ten 2 tane varsa bu da 2 tane 2 üzeri
64'tür. 2 üzeri 60'tan aşağıda 4 tane
varsa bu da 4 tane 2 üzeri 60'tır. Şimdi
işlemlerimizi yapalım. Ne demiştik? 2nin
1 kuvveti ile 2nin 1 kuvveti
çarpılıyorsa yani tabanlar aynı ise
üstler toplanacaktır. Dolayısıyla bu 2
üzeri a + b'dir. Yani 2 x 2 üzeri 64
kaça eşit gelir? Bakın burada gizli bir
1 var. Gizlenmiş. Demek ki yukarısı 2
üzeri 65. 4 x 2 üzeri 60'a bakarsak 4
ifadesi 2 üzeri 2 diye ifade edilebilir.
2 üzeri 60'ı yazdım. Demek ki buradan
kaç gelecekmiş? 2 üzeri 62. Şimdi
işlemimi sonlandıracağım. 2 üzeri 65/
2 üzeri 62 geldi. Ne diyor arkadaşlar?
Yukarıda 65 tane yani şöyle hayal
ederseniz çok rahat anlaşılır. Yukarıda
65 tane 2 var diyor değil mi? Bakın
şurası 65 tane. Aşağıda kaç tane var
peki? Aşağıda da aynısından direkt şöyle
yazalım. 63 tane diyelim. Şimdi pardon
62 tane diyelim. 65 taneyi 62 taneye
oranlıyorsak
o zaman biz yukarıdan bazılarını
silmeliyiz. Bazılarından kastım kaç
tanesini silmeliyiz? Elbette 62 tanesini
silmelisiniz. 65 taneden 62 tanesini
silersek yukarıda kaç tane kalacaktır?
Hadi şurası kalsın mesela 3 tane
kalacaktır. Bu neye eşittir? 2 üzeri
3'e. Siz bunu nasıl söylediniz veya biz
ders anlatırken ne dedik? Bölme
işleminde tabanlar aynıysa yukarıdan
aşağıdakini çıkartacaktınız. Yani bu 65
- 62'den 2 üzeri 3. Buradan da yanıtınız
8 olarak bulunacaktı. Anlaştık mı? Peki
bakalım 3. soruya gelelim. Yine çok
benzer bunlara. Benim size vereceğim en
güzel tavsiye bu soru tipleri için en
küçük dereceli terimin parantezine
almanız. Böylelikle işleriniz çok
rahatlar. Nasıl olacaktır?
Aşağıdakilerden hangisine eşit diyor.
Güya cevaplar vardı. Bazı cevaplar dör
tane çıkmış. Ben bu dosyayı yazarken bir
sürü badire atlattım arkadaşlar. Kusura
bakmayın. Bazı sorularda 4 cevap var.
Bazısında 5 cevap var. Bazısında
çıkmadı. Neyse takılmayalım. Biz
anlatıyoruz işte. Anlarsak bizim için
yeterli. Şimdi basit bitiyor. Ne demek o
basit diyor. 2 üzeri 1, 2 üzeri 2, 2
üzeri 3'ün toplamına bakalım. Arkadaşlar
siz paranteze alırken parantez işlemini
8'de de öğrendiğinizde ne yapmıştınız? x
a + x b - x c bir ifade varsa burada
ortak olanlar x'lerdir. O zaman ben
burayı x parantezine alabilirim. Nasıl
alırım? A B - C şeklinde alırım. Ve bu
X'i dağıttığım zaman da gerçekten şu
yanda yazdığımız açılımı elde ederiz. E
neden burada aynısını yapmıyorsunuz?
Nasıl yapacağız ki? Burada ortak olanlar
yok. Bunların önünde x'ler yok. Aslında
varlar arkadaşlar. O da şöyle
gösterilebilir. 2 üzeri 1'i nasıl
yazarsınız? 2. 2 üzeri 2 nedir? 2 x 2. 2
üzeri 3 nedir? 2 x 2 üzeri 2. Ben tabii
bunu açıklayayım diye böyle yapıyorum.
Bundan sonra böyle yapmayacaksınız ama
ortak paranteze ne ile alınabilir? Tabii
ki de 2 ile alınabilir. 2 parantezinde 1
geriye ne kaldı? 2. Geriye ne kaldı?
Şöyle göstereyim. Boncukların
parantezine aldık. Gizli 1 2 2 üzeri 2.
Gördünüz mü? Paranteze aldık artık. Yani
şuradaki 2 üzeri 1 parantezine almış
oldunuz. Peki yukarıdan yola çıkarsak
hepsinin içerisinde ne var? Bak burada
10 tane 2, 10 tane 2, 11 tane 2, 12 tane
2, 13 tane 2. Hadi gel baştan
başlayalım. 2 tane 2 üzeri 10 var. 2
üzeri 10 + 2 üzeri 10. Ne dedik
yukarıda? Bu 2 tane 2 üzeri 10'dur. Bu
neye eşittir? Gizli 1 vardı burada.
Tabanlar aynıysa üstler toplanacaktı. 2
üzeri 11. O zaman şu sarıyla gösterdiğim
yerin kafasına 2 üzeri 11 yazdım. Şimdi
tekrar boyuyorum. 2 üzeri 11. 2 üzeri
11. O zaman 2 üzeri 11 + 2 üzeri 11. 2
tane 2 üzeri 11. Bu da neye eşittir? 2
üzeri 12. Dolayısıyla şu kısımda kaç
tane? 2 üzeri 12. Yakaladığınızı
düşünüyorum. 2 üzeri 12 ile şuradaki 2
üzeri 12'yi toplarsam 2 üzeri 13. 2
üzeri 13ile buradaki 2 üzeri 13'ü
toplarsam toplamda da ne gelecektir? 2
üzeri 14 gelecektir. Bu işlemleri sakın
ezbere yapmayın. Kafanızda bir zemine
oturursa karşılaştığınız her soruyu bu
şekildeki doğru yaparsınız. Kaldı ki
kareköklü ifadeleri sizlere üslü
ifadelerle anlatacağım. O yüzden üstlü
ifadeleri iyi anlamak demek kareköklü
ifadeler için de konuyu çok daha rahat
anlamak demektir. Şimdi bilimsel
gösterime geldik. Burada muazzam
karışıklık yaşıyorsunuz. Ben açık
söyleyeyim kendi ortaokul dönemimde de
bu konudan hiçbir halt anlamamıştım. Hiç
de sevmemiştim. Tamamen şeffaf bir
şekilde paylaşıyorum. Ama size elbette
neyi görmediğim için konuyu anlamamışım.
Ben onu çok sonradan fark ettim. Onu
açıklayacağım ki siz de benim gibi
anlamıyorsanız hemen aklınıza yatsın. 10
üzeri -1. Buradaki tüm problem bu
arkadaşlar. Burayı anlarsanız
rahatlarsınız gösterimlerde, bilimsel
gösterimlerde. Şimdi eksili ifade ne
demekti? Bir onu konuşalım. 2 üzeri -1'i
nasıl yazdınız siz? Veya ben size
anlatırken de dedim şuradaki eksiyi 1
bölü gibi düşünün. Oradaki eksi 1 bölü
gibiyse geriye kalanı da tutun. Aynen
aşağı yazın. Ne kaldı? 2 üzeri 1. Yani
bu ne demekmiş? 1/2 demekmiş. Hadi bir
tane daha örnek. 2 üzeri -3'e bakalım.
Ne dedim? Şu eksiyi ben diyorum ki 1/
gibi düşünün. Bu eksi bir bölü yapsın.
Geriye kalan neyse aynısını aşağı koyun.
2 üzeri 3. Bu ne demekmiş? 1/8 demekmiş.
A ne güzel. O zaman aynı şeyleri tersten
de yapabiliriz. Yani ben size 1/10'u
soruyorsam 1/10 neye eşit gelecektir? 10
üzeri -1'e. Veya 1'i 10'a bölüyor olmak
demek ne demektir?
1 10'a bölünmez. Dolayısıyla buraya bir
0 koyarsınız. Buraya da bir 0
koyarsınız. ve bir virgül koymanız
gerekecektir. Artık buraya bir 0
koyduğumuz için buraya bir virgül
koymamız gerekecektir. 10 içerisinde 10
bir kere olduğu için bu 10 kere gelir. 0
kaldı. İşlem bitti. Yani 0,1 demekmiş.
Doğrudur aslında. Burayı nasıl
okuyorsunuz Türkçe? Gündelik hayatımızda
hep kullanıyoruz. Onda 1'e bir değil mi?
Ya da ne dersiniz? Oran korunur aslında.
Buraya bir 0, buraya bir 0 koysaydınız
%10'u %10'u diye göstermek aslında o da
şuydu işte. %10 ne demekmiş? 10/100
demekmiş. Bu neye eşit? 1/10 demek. İşte
1'i ile %10'u demek arasında bir fark
görmüyoruz o zaman değil mi? Peki devam
ediyorum. Kafanızı çok karıştırmak
istemiyorum. Demek ki bu ifade 0,1
şeklinde yazılabiliyormuş. Hım. Ben peki
1'i 100'e bölseydim. Bunu nasıl
yazardık? O zaman şöyle demeniz
gerekecekti. 1 100'e bölünmez.
İki tane 0 koyarım. Dolayısıyla yine bir
virgül koymam gerekecekti. Değil mi?
Affedersiniz 20 koyduğum için şöyle
olacaktı. Şimdi virgül koydum çünkü
bölme işlemi yapabiliyorum. Bir kere
var. Aa 1/100 o zaman 0,01 demekmiş.
Hadi bu da kenarda kalsın bize. 0,01
demekmiş. A pardon şurada yanlış yere
koymuşum virgülü. Kusura bakmayın.
E ben bir şeyleri görüyorum. Neyi
görüyorum? Acaba buraya da üstlü
yazsaydık. 10un kaçıncı kuvveti bu? 10un
karesi değil mi? 1/10 karesi. Bunu nasıl
yazabilirdik? 10 üzeri -2 diye
yazabilirdik. İşte bu kadar. Ama şuradan
devam etmek istiyorum. Bu 1/ yandaki
s0fırlarınız kadar aşağıya 0 demektir
arkadaşlar. Tamam mı? Ben bunu
ortaokulda işte kendim derste hiç
anlamamıştım. Artık dedim ki böyle
yapalım. Tunç sayı neyse sayıyı koyduk
buraya. Yanına da o kadar 0 koyalım.
1/100 işte. Şunu sorsaydım ne derdiniz?
0,002
ne olacaktır? 2/ 1000 olacak bu sefer.
Niye 1000? 30.
Anlaştık mı? Kalan ifadeleri de buranın
üssü cinsinden yazarız. Hadi gelin bir
değerlendirelim bakalım ne oluyor.
Şuraları temizliyorum. Kalabalık
etmesinler bizim için. Peki bunlar
kalabilir.
Evet. 1 nanogramdan bahsedilmiş burada
tanımda. Saymaya başlıyorum. Bakın az
önce de öyle yapmıştık. 0,01'i nasıl
yazdık? 1/100. Yani şuradaki 0 kadar. 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9. Demek ki bu nasıl
yazılabilirmiş? 1/ 1
9 tane 0. Yakaladınız mı? 9 tane 0'ı
nasıl yazarsınız? 1/ 10 üzeri 9 diye
yazarız. Bu 1 nmış. 1 nanogram bu kadar
grammış daha doğrusu. Peki 1 nanogramın
gram cinsinden eşiti ne olacaktır? 1/10
üzeri 9. Ama cevaplarda bu yok. Keşke E
şıkkı da olsaydı orada da farklı bir şey
görseydik. Şimdi cevaplardan bir tanesi
demek ki aslında 10 üzeri 1/10 üzeri 9'a
veya 10 üzeri -9'a eşit. Bu cevabı
bulmak istiyoruz. Tamam bulalım hocam.
Olur. A şıkkıyla başlıyorum arkadaşlar.
Şöyle yapalım. Farklı renklerle
göstereyim hatta. 1 2 3 1/ 1 2 3 x 10
üzeri -6 şöyle kalsın. 10 1/1000'i nasıl
yazarsınız? Bu 1/ 10 üzeri 3'tür. X
üzeri -6. Peki burayı nasıl yazarsınız?
1/10 üzeri 3 10 üzeri -3 x 10 üzeri
-6'dır değil mi? Aa aa bunları ne
yapacağız? Toplamayacak mıyız bunları?
Tabii ki çünkü tabanlar aynıysa üstler
toplanır. -3 ile -6'yı topladığınız bu
nereye gidecektir? 10 üzeri -9'a. E biz
zaten bunu arıyormuşuz. O zaman doğru
yanıtımız A şıkkı. Ama ben diğerlerini
de açıklamak istiyorum. B şıkkı
değildir. Bariz belli. Çünkü 10 üzeri -9
olacaktık. Buradan 10 üzeri -8 gelmiş.
Çarpı koyalım. C şıkkına bakalım. 1/ bir
tane 0 1/10 x 10 üzeri -9. 1/10'u nasıl
yazarsınız? 10 üzeri -1 x 10 üzeri -9.
-1 ile -9 toplanırsa dediğimde yanlış
bir şey yok. Kafanız karışmasın. -1 ile
-9 toplanırsa buradan artı ile eksiyi
çarptınız eksi oldu. Demek ki -1 -9'muş.
Bu da -10'muş. Tamam. Kafanız
karışmasın. -1 - 9 10 üzeri -10
olacaktır. E yine uyuşmadı cevabımız da.
Son olarak D şıkkına bakıyorum. D
şıkkında ne diyor? 1 x 10 üzeri -8. E
bunun bunda hiçbir farkı yok ki
arkadaşlar. Bir sayıyı 1 ile çarpmak
demek aslında yine kendisini bulmak
demektir. O sebepten ötürü doğru
yanıtımız A şıkkı olacaktı. Geldim 5'e.
Sayısının 10un kuvvetlerini kullanarak 4
farklı biçimde yazmıştır. Hakan'ın
yazmış olduklarından kaç tanesi doğrudur
peki? 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 tane 0. Şimdi
şunu konuşalım. Biz az önce bunları
gösterdik. Rahatlıkla yazdınız. Peki ben
şöyle bir şey sorsaydım ne derdiniz? 0
mesela 0 ne diyelim?
12 diyelim. Şunu da konuşabiliriz.
1,2'yi konuşalım önce. Vazgeçtim.
Konudan konuya geçeceğiz ama 1,2 1 tam
ne demektir arkadaşlar? Bu bir tane
virgül kaydırdıysanız aslında
12/10'dur bu. Tamam mı? Neden öyle oldu?
Gerçekten 12'yi 10'a bölersek bölelim
bakalım. Bir kere vardır 10 çıktı.
Elimizde 2 kaldı. 2 10'a bölünmez. Ne
yapacaksınız? Bu sefer buraya bir 0
koyduk. Virgül koyuyorum. 2 kere vardır.
20 dedim. Bakın 0 kaldı. 1,2. Veya şöyle
düşünün. 1,2 ile 10'u çarptığımız zaman
yanıtımız kaça gitmeliymiş? 12'ye. O
zaman ne ile 10'u çarparsak 12'ye
gideriz? Tabii ki de 12/10'la.
Heh. Buradan yola çıkarak yine
temizliyorum.
Eğer şöyle işlemler yapıyorsanız örneğin
2,9 diyelim. Kaç tane basamak
kaydırmışsınız? Bakın 1. O zaman sayının
aynısını yazıp kaydırdığımız kadar 0ırlı
da bir basamak kaymış ya da virgül
sağında bir tane sayı var. Bir tane 0
koyacağız. Aynı şeyi şöyle
düşünebilirdiniz. 227
diyelim mesela. Buraya virgül koyayım.
Virgülden sonra kaç basamak var? 1. O
zaman burası 227/
10 olacaktır. Peki 2,27 deseydik ne
derdiniz? 227/
100 derdiniz o zaman. Anlaştık mı? Peki
şöyle bir şey konuşalım. 0,13 olsun.
Buna ne dersiniz arkadaşlar? Yukarıdaki
sayıyı aynen yine yazarım. Yine 0'ın
sağında kalan kadar 1 2 13 2 basamaklı
değil mi? 13/100'dür. 0,14
124/
1 2 3 1 2 3'tür. Geriye kalan bunların
üslü sayılardaki süslü işlemleri çok
böyle şey oldu değil mi ya? Rap yapar
gibi oldu. Üslü sayıların süslü
işlemleri arkadaşlar. Geriye kalan ben
bunlara matematikte makyaj diyorum.
Geriye kalanlar makyaj olacak. Yani
bunlar makyajsız halleri. Anlaştık mı?
Yakaladınız bence ne demek istediğimi.
Hadi sorumuzu çözelim. 10 tane sıfır
varsa yanda bu sayıyı nasıl
yazacaksınız? Ben de şöyle vereyim size.
0,001 vereyim mesela ya da 0,0023
vereyim mesela. Bu sayıyı nasıl
yazacaksınız? H önce daha basit
başlayalım. 023'ü nasıl yazdınız? 23/
100 diye yazdık. 0,023 nasıl yazarsınız?
23/
1 2 3 1000 diye. Yani 1 2 3 şuradaki 0
kadar virgülden sonraki O zaman ben
tekrar sayım çünkü buradaki sıfırları
saymışım. 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 Devam ediyor
muyum? Tabii ki 10 11 taneymiş. Burası
11 basamaklıymış. Ne dersiniz? 73/ 1 tık
tık tık 1. Buraya da 11 tane dedim. Bunu
nasıl yazacağız o zaman? 73/
10 üzeri 11 diye yazacakmışız. Şimdi
cevaplarımız hangileriyle örtüşüyor?
Bunu değerlendirelim. 1inci şıka bakalım
lütfen. 73 x 10 üzeri -11. Doğru mu?
Elbette doğrudur. Neden? 73/ 10 üzeri 11
hatta 1/ 10 üzeri 11 neye eşitti? 10
üzeri -11'e. E 73 tanesi de 73 x 10
üzeri -11 diye. Ya da şuradaki işte 10
üzeri 11'i bu şekilde yazarsanız doğru
gelir. Devam ediyorum. 2inci duruma
bakalım. İkinci duruma şöyle bir boncuk
koydum. Pembe e harf. Pembe harf değil
pembe harf olur mu? Pembe kalemimi
kullanıyorum. Evet diyemedim. Nasıl
yazacağız? 73. 1 2 3 tane var. O zaman
73/
3 tane 0 şöyle olacakmış. Tamam. 1000
olacakmış.
Xar 10 üzeri -9. Burayı nasıl yazarsınız
arkadaşlar? 73 x 10 üzeri kaç 0 var? 1 2
3. O zaman -3 x 10 üzeri -9. Üstler
toplanacaktı. Bu kaç gelir? 73 x 10
üzeri -12. Dolayısıyla bu yanlıştır. Biz
-11 olacaktık. Geliyorum diğer şıka.
Maviyile yapalım bunu da. 7300. Şimdi
7300 x 10 üzeri -15'i 7300'ü nasıl
yazarız? 20 varsa 73 x 10 üzeri 2 x 10
üzeri -15 -15 ile 2'yi toplarsanız kaç
gelir? 73 x 10 üzeri -13 gelir. Doğru
mu? Olmadı. Çünkü biz 10 üzeri 11'e
bakıyorduk. Bu da arkadaşlar yanlış
olacaktır. Şimdi şu renge bakalım. Son
işlemimiz 7,3. 7,3 kaça eşit? 7,3 10
üzeri 10 tabii ki de 73/10 bir basamak
kaymış. Çarpı 10 üzeri 10. Bu ne
demektir? 73 x 10 üzeri -1 x 10 üzeri 10
demektir. Üstler toplanacaktı çünkü
tabanlar aynı. 10 üzeri -1 ile 10 üzeri
10'u topladık. Kaç buluruz? 73 x 10
üzeri 9 buluruz. Bu zaten aradığımız
cevaptan çok çok uzak. Neden arkadaşlar?
Burası 10 üzeri 10. Bu kocaman bir sayı.
Bu küçücük bir sayı. Dolayısıyla bu
şıkka aslında bakmaya bile gerek yoktu
ama işlem yapmak açısından size
anlattım. 5. sorumuzun doğru yanıtı A
şıkkı yalnız 1 olacaktır. Gelelim sağ
tarafa. Evet, sağ taraftayız. Ay ile
güneş arasındaki uzaklık yaklaşık olarak
şu kadar kilometredir diyor. Bilimsel
gösterim sorusu. Çok klasik bir bilimsel
gösterim sorusu. Ne demiştik? Sıfırları
sayacağız demiştik. 1 2 3 4 5 kaç? 192 x
10 üzeri 5. Aslında bu sayı üslü olarak
böyle gösteriliyor. Tamam. Yine şık şık
ilerleyelim. A şıkkına bakalım. 1,92 x
10 üzeri 7. 1,92'yi nasıl yazıyorsunuz?
Az önce ne demiştik? Virgülün sağındaki
basamak sayısı kadar. Yani önce 192'yi
yazdınız. Çarpı ya da açıkça göstereyim.
192/
1 2. O zaman 2 s0lıya böldünüz değil mi?
xar 10 üzeri 7'ymiş. E burası artık ne
olarak yazacak? 10 üzeri 2. Şunu da
görün. Hızlı işlem yapalım. 10 üzeri
7'yi 10 üzeri 2'ye bölürsem bölürsem kaç
kalır? 10 üzeri 5 kalır. Bölürsem o
zaman bu şık 10 üzeri 5. Doğru. A şıkkı
doğru. B'ye bakalım. Evet. Bölürsem
arkadaşlar B. 192 x 10 üzeri 8. Yani
yanlış. Niye ya? Bu doğruysa bu yanlış
olacak zaten. O ayrı konu. Şu yüzden
yanlış olacak. A şıkkını seçtik diye
değil. Bak 1,92 ile 10 üzeri 7'yi
çarptığımızda ben 192 x 10 üzeri 5
buluyorsam 1,92'yi de 10 üzeri 8'i
çarptığımda da ne bulacağım? 192 x 10
üzeri 6 bulacağım. İşte bir fazlası oldu
çünkü 0. Gördünüz mü? O yüzden
yazmayayım demiştim. Aynı şey aşağısı
için de geçerli. Burası da 192 x 10
üzeri 4. Çünkü 1 azalmış. Şimdi şuna
bakalım. 0,192 x 10 üzeri 8. Bu 192/ 1 2
3'tür. 1 2 3'tür. X üzeri 8. Ne
yaparsınız? Aşağıya 10 üzeri 3 diye
yazarsınız. 10 üzeri 8'i 10 üzeri 3'e
böldüğümüzde kaç geliyor? Doğru
gösteriyorsak değil mi? 192 x 10 üzeri
evet 3/ 10 üzeri 8 şuradan 10 üzeri 5
geliyor. O zaman burası 192 x 10 üzeri 5
olacaktır. Harika bir yere geldik. İşte
bu şıkları uzun uzun anlatmamın sebebi
buydu. Bize verilen soru kökünü iyi
okuyalım. Zaten sizin üniteniz de böyle
veriliyor arkadaşlar. Bilimsel gösterim.
Şimdi gelin bakalım neymiş bilimsel
gösterim. Burayı temizliyorum. Doğru
cevabımız A olacak. Sebebini
açıklayayım. Bilimsel gösterim dediğimiz
şey iyice yaklaşalım. Hatta şöyle ben
küçük bir kalemle anlatayım size.
Bilimsel gösterim dediğimiz şey de sizin
üst olarak ya biz burada 2 üzeri x
diyorsak bu sayıya ne diyoruz? Aslında
tabanı diyoruz. Değil mi? Bu tabandaki
sayınız arkadaşlar 1 ile 10 aralığında
olmalı. Anlaştık mı? Eğer bu olmuyorsa
sayınız 1'den küçük ve 1den büyük ve
eşit özür dilerim ondan küçük olmuyorsa
biz bu ifadelere bilimsel gösterim
demeyiz. Niye mutlak değer var? Çünkü
eksili bir ifade de olsa onun aynı
şekilde yazabilmeniz açısından buraya
mutlak değer koyuyorum. Bu şekilde olan
şeyler bizim için bilimsel gösterimdir.
Yani şu 0ın 0,192'si bilimsel gösterime
girmiyor. Biz bunu illa göstermek
istiyorsak nasıl yazmalıydık? Şimdi
onları konuşalım. Sayılarınız hangi
aralıkta olacakmış? 1 ile 10 aralığında.
Bakın 19,2 dediğimiz ifadeyi de aslında
tekrar düzeltelim. Bu da bir bilimsel
gösterim belirtmiyor. Bunu nasıl
yazacaksınız? Bir tane 0 sola yani şu
virgülü sola almamız lazım. Ne yaparsak
o virgül sola kayar? Söyleyin bakalım.
Sayıyı on 10'a bölersek mi? Şöyle
düşünün. 32 sayısının bilimsel gösterimi
yani basit sorayım. Nasıl yapılır? E bir
virgül koymamız lazım. Çünkü şuradaki
sayı 1 ile 10 aralığında olmalı, değil
mi? 0'dan önceki sayımız 1 ve 10
aralığında olmalı. O zaman biz hemen
daha açık yazarsam 10 a x 10 üzeri n
işte bunlar bilimsel gösterimdir. Bu a 1
ile 10 aralığında olacaksa 32 sayısı
bilimsel gösterim olmaz. 3,2 sayısı
bilimsel gösterim olur. 32'yi 3,2
cinsinden nasıl yazarız? Onu sormak
istiyorum. Eğer 3,2 deseydiniz bu
32/10'dur.
E buraya 10 havadan geldi. Demek ki
burayı 10'la çarpmalısınız. Yani burası
3,2 x 10 gelecekti veya 10 üzeri 1
gelecekti. Aslında kaydırdığınız virgül
kadar 10'la çarpıyor olacaktık. Umarım
anlaşılır olmuştur. Bir tane daha
sorayım. 456'yı
bilimsel olarak gösterseydik ne
olacaktı? Şuraya virgül koymalıydım. Kaç
basamak kaydırdım? 2. O zaman 4,56 x 10
üzeri 2 demeliyim. Çünkü 4,56 dediğimiz
sayı ne gelecektir? 456/
1 2 456/100 yani 456/
10 üzeri 2 gelecektir. Şimdi D şıkkına
gelelim. Ne kadar cevap aynı gelmiş?
Sayı olarak aynı gelmiş olsa da sizlere
bir bilimsel gösterim soruyor. O yüzden
0,92'yi 1 yani artık buranın tam sayısı
1 ile başlanmak zorunda olduğu için 1'e
getirmeliyiz. Onu düşünelim. Burayı
sonra yaparız. Hiç düşünmeyin.
192/1 2 3 Az önce de yapmıştık. Bu sayı
budur. Hım. Ben bu sayıyı o zaman neye
benzetmeliyim? Ya da burayı şöyle
diyelim isterseniz. 192 x 10 üzeri -3
değil mi? Bir de burada 10 üzeri 8
vardı. Burada da 10 üzeri 8 vardı. Hah.
İfademiz şu geldi arkadaşlar. 192'yi
nasıl yazacağız? 1,92 değil mi? 1,92
çarpı ne diyeceğiz? Tabii ki de 100
diyeceğiz. 2 basamak kaydırdık. O zaman
şu 192 yerine 1,92 x 100 x 10 üzeri -3 x
10 üzeri 8 deseydiniz. Şimdi işlem
yapıyorum. 1,92
10 üzeri 2 gelecektir. 10 üzeri -3 ile
topladım 10 üzeri -1 üzeri 8ile topladım
10 üzeri 7 geldi. Bu bizim aradığımız
cevapla aynı şey olacaktır. A şıkkıyla.
Evet. Ama bu gösterim yanlış olduğu için
yanıtınız D şıkkı değildir. Y cevaplar
önemli değil. Dediğim gibi bilimsel
gösterimi yaparken şu şekilde A
şıkkındaki gibi göstermeniz gerekiyor. A
x 10 üzeri N şeklindeki gösterimlere biz
bilimsel gösterim diyoruz. Tamam.
Gelelim 7'ye. Temel bir işlem sorusu
sormak istedim. Birazcık daha geriye
çıkayım. Şöyle daha rahat görün.
Elimizde bir karınca var. Tüm
yüzeylerinin kenar uzunlukları 2 üzeri 5
olan bir küp. Küpler aslında küp de
değil. Sadece küpler var elimizde. Eş
karelerden oluşmuş diyor. Onu söylüyor.
Bunlar küp belirtiyor. A noktasına
hareket eden karınca B'ye varacak. Şimdi
arkadaşlar küpün eğer içinden
geçmiyorsak dış ayrıtlarının dış
uzunluklarının her birisi ne gelecektir?
Eşit gelecektir. Değil mi? Bunlar bir
kareymiş çünkü. Yani şurası da şurası da
şurası da. Bunların hepsi birbirlerine
eşit. Bakın bir hamle yaptı bu karınca.
Farklı renkte göstermeye çalışayım. Bir
hamle yaptı. 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 tane birim yürüdü. Her birim 2
üzeri 5 cm ise o zaman 16 tane 2 üzeri
5'in neyine bakacaksınız?
Toplamına 16 tane. Burada işte santim
cinsinden verilmiş. Size tekrar metre
falan cinsinden sorup bu ondalıklı
gösterimlere getirebilirdi sizi burada.
Ama öyle bir şey yok. 2 üzeri 5 x 16
diyecektik. 16 neye eşitti? 2 üzeri 5 x
2 üzeri 4'e buradan da üstleri topladık
2 üzeri 9 cm diyecektik. Tamam. Ya da
hadi ben sorayım kaç metredir diye
sorayım soruyu. Belki hocanız hani böyle
sizi düşürmek için belki böyle sorarsa
düşmeyin. En azından burada konuşmuş
olalım. Kaç metre olacaktır? Eee neyi
biliyorsunuz? 100 cm
1 metredir. O zaman 1 cm kaç metre
olacaktır? 0,01 m. Bunu nasıl yaptık?
Bak şimdi santim 100 katına çıkmış. O
zaman neyin 100 katı 1dir? 1/100'ün.
Aslında şöyle düşünebilirsiniz, değil
mi? Ya da 100'ü kaça bölersek 1 gelir?
100'e bölersek. O zaman 1'i de 100'e
bölecektiniz. Doğru orantı var bunların
arasında. 1/100 m. Hım. 1/100 m 0,01 m
demektir. Yani 1 cm 0,01 m demektir. O
halde 2,9 cm 2,9 x 0,01 metredir. Ya da
2,9 x 10 üzeri ne diyeceksiniz? Şuradan
söyleyin. 10 üzeri -2 metredir. Tamam.
Belki kilometre sorulabilirdi. Hani
farklılık olsun diye söylüyorum. O
birimleri iyi bilin. Desimetre,
kilometre. Yani her birinin uzaklığı
birbiriyle kaç kat artıyor? Bunları
lütfen iyi bilin. 8. sorudayız. Dünya,
Venüs, Jüpiter, Uranüs diye gezegenlerin
isimleri yazılmış ve güneşe olan
uzaklıkları belirtilmiş. Jüpiter'in
güneşe uzaklığı diyor. Şimdi oraya
geçmeden önce hemen şunları halledelim
arkadaşlar. Burada bir 24'ün karesi var.
Ne demek bu? 24 3 x 8 olarak
yazılabilirse aynı zamanda 3 x 2 üzeri 3
olarak yazılabilir. O halde 24'ün karesi
ne demektir? Buranın karesi demektir.
Buranın karesinde ne olur arkadaşlar?
3'ün 2. kuvveti çarp 2 üzeri
3ün karesi yani 2 üzeri 6. Sebep üssün
üssü
çarpılırdı değil mi? O yüzden 2 üzeri 6
derdik. Yani bu ifade şöyle
açılmalıymış. Demek ki dünyaya olan
uzaklığı bunlar yanda dursun. Ne
kadarmış? 3ün karesi. Başka 3 yok. Bakın
doğrudan yazıyorum. Hatta 2 ile
başlayalım. 2 üzeri 7 2 üzeri 6 daha 2
üzeri 13 x 3 üzeri 2 x 5 üzeri 6 dedim.
Aşağı geldim. Venüs elleyecek hiçbir şey
yok. 11 asal sayı bıraktım. Jüpiter'de
18 var. 18 ne demektir? 2 x 9. Bu neye
eşittir? 2 x 3 üzeri 2'ye. Şimdi şuradan
bir tane 2 geldi. Burada 2 üzeri 9 var.
2 üzeri 10 x 3 üzeri 2 x 5 üzeri 7
geldi. Aşağıya bakalım. 22'yi nasıl
yazarsınız? 2 x 11 diye yazarım. 12'nin
küpü var. Düşünelim. 12 ne demektir? 4 x
3 yani 2 karesi x 3. Buranın 3.
kuvvetini alıyorsak buranın 3. kuvvetini
almalıyız. 2 üzeri 2nin 3'ü 2 üzeri 6 3
üzeri 3 gelecektir. O zaman arkadaşlar
bir tane 2 buradan geldi. 2 üzeri 6 da
buradan geldi. 2 üzeri 7 3 üzeri 3
gelecek. Koydum 5 üzeri 7 gelecek.
Hepsini 2 3 5 7 11 yani asallarıyla
yazdım. Zaten amaçta o arkadaşlar.
Asallarıyla ifade etmek. Devam edelim.
Jüpiter'in güneşe olan uzaklığı hani
Jüpiter'in güneşe olan uzaklığı şu sayı.
Şu 2 üzeri 10 x 3 üzeri 2 x 5 üzeri 7.
Dünyanın güneşe olan uzaklığının a katı.
Bu dünyanın güneşe olan uzaklığının 2
üzeri 13 x 3 üzeri 2 x 5 üzeri 6
sayısının a katıymış. Peki a'yı nasıl
buluruz? Bu ifadeyi buraya bölerek
buluruz. Elbette bu da a'yı verecektir
bize. Hadi hemen bölelim. 2 üzeri 10.
13'e böldüm. Aşağıda ne kaldı? 2 üzeri 3
kaldı. Farklarını alacağız çünkü bölme
işleminde. Hatırlayın konuşmuştuk bunu.
3 üzeri 2 3 üzeri 2 ile gitti. 5 üzeri 7
5 üzeri 6'ya böldüm. Yukarıda bir 5
kaldı. A sayısı buymuş. Venüs'ün güneşe
uzaklığı Uranüs'ün güneşe olan
uzaklığının B katı. Venüs'ün Venüs'ün
güneşe uzaklığı Uranüs'ün güneşe olan
uzaklığının V katı. Tamam. Venüs'ün
güneşe uzaklığı şurası. 11 x 2 üzeri 7 x
5 üzeri 8.
Uranüs'ün güneşe olan uzaklığının 2
üzeri 7. En alttakini yazıyorum
arkadaşlar. 3 üzeri 3 5 üzeri 7'nin B
katıymış. O zaman bu ifadeyi buraya
bölersek b'yi buluruz. Tamam.
B neye eşittir? 11 kaldı yukarıda.
Yazdım.
Şu gitti. 2 üzeri 7'ler gitti. 5 üzeri 8
5 üzeri 7'ye böldüm. Yukarıda 5 kaldı.
Aşağıda da 3 üzeri 3 kaldı. Tamam. Şimdi
A'nın B'ye oranını soruyor. Hadi bakalım
işlem yapalım. A'nın B'ye oranı 5/ 2
üzeri 3'ün>> B 11 x 5/ 3 üzeri 3'e
oranı. Bu neye eşittir? 5/2 üzeri 3'ün
aşağıdakini takla attırıp yukarı
getirdim. 3 üzeri 3 11 x 5'e oranına. Şu
5'ler birbirlerini götüreceklerdir.
Peki 3 üzeri 3 yukarıda kaldı.
Tamam cevaplardan gideyim. Aşağıda ne
kaldı? 11 de var ama burada değil mi?
Biz bu 11'i buradan kaldıramadık
sanırım. Bir yerden gitmeli miydi acaba?
Niye bulamıyoruz?
Evet. Şu Venüs'ün Venüs'ün Uranüs'a olan
uzak diyor. Acaba ben şurada mı yanlış
yaptım? Çok özür dilerim. Bir daha
dikkatli bakayım. Venüs'ün güneş olduğ.
Peki Uranüs'ün güneşe olan uzaklığı
tamam. 2 üzeri 7. E burada o zaman şu
11'i Evet yazmayı unutmuşum kusura
bakmayın. 22 yazınca bir tane de 11
gelecek. Tabii ki kesin kafayı yediniz
değil mi beni dinlerken? Evet. Böyle
saçlarınızı falan yolup 11'i yaz artık
oraya falan demiş olabilirsiniz.
Düzeltiyorum. Düzelttim. Pardon. Çok
sinir bozucu. Evet. Of, çok kötü
hissediyorum. Hemen düzeltiyorum.
Düzelttik, düzelttik, düzelttik. 5'ler
gitti. Kaç kaldı? 3 üzeri 3/ 2 üzeri 3.
Nasıl yazarız? 2 üzeri -3 x 3 üzeri 3
diye yazarız. Tamam, hallettim,
hallettim. Kızmayın bana. Hadi gelelim
9. soru. Buna benzer çok çözdük bugün. O
yüzden tüyomuz belli. Tüyomuz neydi? En
küçük kuvvetin parantezine önce
yukarıyla başlayalım. 2 üzeri 94
parantezinde 2 üzeri 94'ü ne ile
çarparsam 2 üzeri 94 gelir? 1 ile 2
üzeri 94'ü ne ile çarparsam 2 üzeri 95
gelir? 2 ile. Ne ile çarparsam 96 gelir?
4ile dikkat edin buraya eksik koyuyorum.
Ya da 2 üzeri 2 gibi de
düşünebilirsiniz. Bölü aşağıdaki en
küçük sayı 91. 91 parantezinde 91 ile
neyi çarparsam 93'e giderim? 2 üzeri 2
ek ortası eksi. Ne ile çarparsam 92'ye
giderim? 2 ile. Ne ile çarparsam 91
olur? + 1 ile buradan ne bulurum? 2
üzeri 94 x 1 2 daha 3 2 üzeri 2 -4'tür
yani 3 -4 yani -1 geldi böl 2 üzeri 91 x
2 üzeri 2 4 2 çıktı 2 1 daha ekledik 3
geldi şimdi işlem yapalım 2 üzeri 94'ü 2
üzeri 91'e oranlıyorsak neydi bölüm
durumunda tabanlar aynıysa üsler
çıkarılır. 94'ten 91 çıktı. 2 üzeri 3
kaldı. Burası da -1. Burası da 3. Ne
olacak o zaman? 2 üzeri 8. 2 üzeri 3
özür dilerim 8. -1 ile çarptım. -8/3.
Doğru yanıtımız B şıkkı gelecekti. 10.
soru. Ondalıklı gösterimler de var.
Muhteşem. Hadi başlayalım. Nasıl
yazacağız bu ifadeyi? Sıra sıra soldan
sağa gideceğim. 2/ 2 tane basamak var.
2/100'ün küpü. 2/100'ü nasıl yazarsınız?
2/ 10 üzeri 2in küpü. Bunu nasıl
yazarız? 2in küpü 10 üzeri 2nin küpünden
ne gelir? 10 üzeri 6 çarp 1/
2 3 1 2 3 bunu nasıl yazarız? 1/ 10
üzeri 3. Bunun neyinci kuvveti? -2
kuvvetini alıyoruz. O zaman 1/ -2 yine
1'dir. 10 üzeri 3 üzeri -2 10 üzeri -6
gelecektir. Arkadaşlar 1/10 üzeri -6
nedir? Biz 10 üzeri -6'yı 1/10 üzeri 6
diye yazmıyor muyuz? E 1/6 şey 1/10
üzeri 6 burası 10 üzeri 6 gelecek
aslında. Tamam. Kafasına yazabilirim
isterseniz. Şurası 10 üzeri 6 gelecek.
Devam ediyorum. 0,12'nin -1. kuvveti
nedir bu? 12/100'dür.
Bakın 12/100. Nasıl yazarsınız?
12/ 10 üzeri 2. Bunun -1 kuvveti 12
üzeri -1/ 10 üzeri -2 diye yazılacaktır.
Ya da şöyle düşünebilirsiniz. Hocam
burası 12/100 değil mi? Evet. Bunun -1
kuvveti mi? Evet. E nedir bu? 1/ diye
yazarsak 100/12'dir aslında. Bence böyle
de yazabilirdiniz. Ben hadi öyle
bırakayım. 100/12 olsun. Büyük bölü
aşağıdayım. 8/ kaç geliyor? 1 2 3 8/
1000 yazdım.
çarpı 24/ kaç gelecektir? 1 2 3. Dikkat
edin. 1 2 3 yine 1000. Bunun -1 kuvveti.
Bunun -1 kuvveti nedir? Yine arkadaşlar
takla atacaktık. 1000/
24'tür. Ben bunu da böyle yazarım. Şimdi
işlem yapalım. Bakın burası 10 üzeri 6
geliyorsa buranın da paydasında 10 üzeri
6 yok mu? Bu sayıların çarpımı ne gelir?
Yani şurası 10 üzeri 6. 10 üzeri 6 ile
1/ 10 üzeri 6'yı çarparsak 1 demek ki
yukarıda 2 üzeri 3 kaldı.
X 100/12. Şimdi şu 2 üzeri 8 kaça eşit?
2 üzeri 8 deyip duruyorum affedersiniz.
2 üzeri 3 kaça eşit? 8'e. 8 x 100/12/
1000'ler gitti. 8/24 kaça eşit? 1/ 3'e
eşit. Peki 8'i 4'e böldüm 2. 8'i 4'e
böldüm 3. Yani bu sayı 200/3'müş.
böl 1/3'müş. 200/3/ 1/3. Aşağıdaki ifade
takla atıp yukarı gelseydi 200/3 x 3/1
yani 200 gelecekmiş. Yanıtı 200 olan bir
şık. Evet doğrudan var bu sefer. Çok
uğraştırmadı. E şıkkı olarak
söyleyecektik. Şimdi kalan son sorum
var. Onu da çözüp sizlere rahat
bırakıyorum. Artık öyle diyeceğim. Kayıt
uzadı çünkü.
Aşağıda kenar uzunlukları 25 ve 5 üzeri
4 - 5 üzeri 3 olan dikdörtgen şeklindeki
duvar kağıtları yan yana
yapıştırılacaktır. Buna göre duvarın
kapladığı alan kaç birim karedir diye
sorulmuş. Şimdi bakın burada büyük
olarak verilen dikdörtgenler var. Evet.
Niye şekil gitti? Hiçbir fikrim yok.
Şöyle tekrar yapalım. Büyük olarak
verilen dikdörtgenler var ve bunlardan 2
üzeri 6 tane verilmiş. Önce bunların
alanını bulalım. Bir tanesinin alanı ne
gelecektir? Şu siyahla boyadığımızın
alanı 25 x 5 üzeri 4 - 5 üzeri 3
gelecektir. 25'i nasıl yazarsınız? 5
üzeri 2. Burayı nasıl yazarız? Bakın 5
üzeri 4'ten 5 üzeri 3 çıkıyorsa bu da 5
üzeri 3 parantezinde 5 - 1 şeklinde
yazılabilir. Bu neye eşit gelecektir?
5in karesi x 5 üzeri 3 parantezinde 5 -
1'den ne gelir? 4 gelir değil mi? 5
üzeri 5 x 4 gelmiyor mu?
Oldu. 5 üzeri 5 x 4. Bu bir tanesinin
alanı. Bundan elimizde kaç tane var? 2
üzeri 6 tane. Şuraya kadar olanı önce
konuşuyorum arkadaşlar. 2 üzeri 6 tane 5
üzeri 5 x 4. Yani 2 üzeri 6 x 5 üzeri 5
x 4. dediğimiz sayı kaça eşit gelecek? 2
üzeri 2 değil mi? O zaman bunu da öyle
geniş ya genişletelim demeyeyim. Öyle
açalım. Çarpım durumundan ne gelir? 2
üzeri 8 x
5 üzeri 5 gelir. Bu bu alan. Şimdi
kalana gelelim. Burası 25, burası 25, 5
üzeri 4, 5 üzeri 3 yan çevirmiş. Biz kaç
bulmuştuk orayı? 5 üzeri 5 x 4. Bu sefer
bundan da 2 üzeri 4 tane. Yani 2 üzeri 4
tane 5 üzeri 5 x 4. Bu da 2 üzeri 4 tane
5 üzeri 5 x 2 üzeri 2. Buradan da 2
üzeri 6 x 5 üzeri 5 derdik. Demek ki
şunları bulduk. Bunların toplamı da bize
tüm alanı verir. 2 üzeri 8, 5 üzeri 5,
5 üzeri 5, 2 üzeri 6. Ne parantezine
alalım? Ortak olanlar ne? Acele etmeyin.
5 üzeri 5 x 2 üzeri 6 parantezine
alalım. 2 üzeri 6 ile kaçı çarparsak 2
üzeri 8 gelir? 2 üzeri 2'yi. 5 üzeri 5,
2 üzeri 6 tabii ki de 1 ile çarparsak bu
nedir? 5 üzeri 5 x 2 üzeri 6 x 2 üzeri 2
4 1 daha 5 üzeri neyse bir satır daha
yazayım. 5 üzeri 6 x 2 üzeri 6 çok
güzel. Bu soruyu yine sorma amacımız
üsler aynıysa tabanlar
toplanır değil. Dikkat çarpılır. Tabii
ki de tabanlar çarpılır. Bu da 10 üzeri
6 olacaktır. Doğru yanıtız C şıkkı
gelecekti. Evet son iki soru çözüp
bitiriyoruz. Yine bir aslında bilimsel
gösterim gibi değil ama değil mi?
Doğrudan bir sü sayı sorusu sanırım bu.
Geri dönüşüme kazandıracağımız 2,6 kg
kağıt ile bir ağaç kurtarabiliriz.
Tamam. 2,6 kilo kağıt bir tane ağaç. O
zaman şöyle yazalım.
Bir ağaç ise günde 4 insanın tükettiği
oksijen. O zaman bir ağaç da ney? 4
insanın oksijenine. Yani biz 2,6 kiloluk
kağıdı kurtarırsak 4 insanın günlük
oksijen tüketim miktarını karşılamış
olacağız. Anlaştık. 4 insan demek ne
demektir? 2 üzeri arkadaşlar 2 üzeri 2
insan demektir. Değil mi? Onu da şöyle
yazalım. Şimdi 2 üzeri 8 insanın
tükettiği oksijenin üretebilmesi için
kaç kilo kağıt? Çok güzel. Şimdi 2 üzeri
2 insan. Biz bunu kaçla çarparsak doğru
oran olacak çünkü burada değil mi? Doğru
orantı olacak. 2 üzeri 8'e gider. Kaç
katı 2 üzeri 8'dir? 2 üzeri 2'nin 2
üzeri 6 katı. O zaman umarım bir he
engel oluyor muyum? Tabii ki de kameram
engel oluyor. Şöyle yapalım. Kusura
bakmayın.
Heh, şimdi daha rahat gözüküyordur. O
zaman 2 üzeri 6 katı 2 üzeri 8 ise
buranın da 2 üzeri 6 katı alınmalı. 2
üzeri 6'nın 2 üzeri 6 katı neye eşit
gelecektir? Tabii ki de 2 üzeri 12'ye.
Tamam. Bu doğru orantılı sorulara dikkat
edin. O yüzden bu soruyu koymuştum.
Şimdi son sorumuz. Evet. K sayısı 2
üzeri -3, 2 üzeri -4, 2 üzeri -5. Ben bu
sorularda hep papağan gibi ne söylüyorum
size? En küçüğün parantezine alım.
Burada en küçük hangisi? Tabii ki de
burada en küçük. Azıcık soruyu büyüteyim
daha rahat görün. Yerim var zaten.
Buradaki en küçük arkadaşlar -5'tir.
Burayı -5 parantezine alacaksınız. O
zaman k sayısı 2 üzeri -5 parantezinde.
Niye? -5 ile neyi çarparsam 2 üzeri -3
olur? Yani ne ile toplarsam gibi
düşünün. Tabii ki de burası 2 üzeri 2
olmalı. -5 ile 2'nin toplamı bakın -3'e
gidecekti. + 2 diyecektim. -4'e
gidecekti. + 1 diyecektim. L ne gelir? 2
üzeri -7 parantezinde 1 + 2 + bu sefer 2
üzeri 2 gelecekti. Hemen işlemlerimizi
yapalım. 2 üzeri -5 x 2 kere 2nin 2.
kuvveti 4 2 6 1 daha 7 buradan ne gelir?
2 üzeri -7 x yine 7 gelir. L sayısı K
sayısının kaç katıdır? L sayısıyla bir
şeyi çarpınca K sayısını veriyormuş.
Yıldızı bulmaya çalışıyoruz. O zaman
yıldızı bulmak için K'yı L''ye
oranlayalım. K dediğiniz yukarısı, L
dediğiniz aşağısı. Bir kere şu 7'ler
gitti. Ne yapacaktık arkadaşlar? Bölüm
durumunda tabanlar aynıysa üstlerin
farkı. Ama dikkat üstlerin farkı derken
2 üzeri -5/ 2 üzeri -7 bu 2 üzeri -5 -
aşağısı 2 üzeri -7. Şimdi ne var burada?
2 tane eksi birbirine artı yapacağı için
bu 2 üzeri -5 + 7'den 2 üzeri 2. Buradan
da yanıtız 4 gelecektir. Tamam. Çok
güzel oldu vallahi. Anlatırken keyifle
anlattım. Üslü sayılarla ilgili belki
yine daha soru çözümü yaparız.
Yorumlarınız çok çok önemli. PDF'leri
katıl kısmına koyuyorum. Açıklamada
katılın linki olacak. Bilginiz olsun.
Yorumlarda belirtin. Beğenmediğiniz,
beğendiğiniz köklü sayılarda mısınız?
Konu olarak neredesiniz? Nerenin üstüne
düşelim? Bunların hepsini okuyor
olacağım. İzlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim. Videoyu beğenip paylaşmayı
lütfen unutmayın. Hepinize bol
başarılar.